powerful storm is threatening to trigger
dangerous mudslides in Southern
California today as it moves through
areas devastated by wildfires in
December thirty thousand people across
35 miles are under mandatory evacuation
orders that includes Montecito where
heavy rain caused deadly mudslides
earlier this year
Mireya Villarreal is there this morning
Maria good morning good morning
officials here are worried about creeks
just like this one that are already
moving at a very fast pace they're
worried they could turn into
debris-filled rivers right now the rain
has already started to come down pretty
heavy but the worst of the storm isn't
even expected until later this morning
people in this area have been evacuated
three times since January but officials
tell me right now they're not taking any
chances with people's safety
the heaviest rain started falling on
Montecito this morning renewing fears of
more mudslides which caught many living
here off-guard in January oh my god
those mud sites killed 21 people with
two children still missing huge boulders
were swept into neighborhoods by the
strength of the storm which officials
say could happen again
battalion chief adam Estabrook the
vegetation is not there to hold these
rocks and boulders in so as it gets
wetter we're starting to have some of
those boulders come loose and they'll
come rolling down those mountains as
many as 10 inches of rain could fall
before this storm is over it's almost
double the amount of rain that we had it
when we have the January incident the
rain is already caused flooding and
closed roads in nearby ventura county in
Los Angeles County the saturated ground
caused this seven year old pine tree to
fall across a street into another
property no one was injured
meanwhile officials in Montecito know
just how devastating the storms can be
is there a possibility that lightning
could strike twice to get in this area
well we hope not it just all depends on
you know how much rain we get and how
fast we get in and we're hoping for the
best there are an additional four
hundred first responders on standby
right now in case of an emergency
experts are predicting we could see up
to an inch of rain
per hour in some areas which could lead
to some flash flooding right now there
is a flash flood warning in effect that
goes through 5:00 p.m. tonight already
this morning we've seen this Creek rise
pretty fast and we've actually heard
boulders coming downstream
Matea thank you